hey everybody thank you so much for
checking out our post III video my name
is Mike Laidlaw I'm the creative
director for Dragon Age Inquisition and
today we're going to show you how our
mix of exploration real-time and
tactical combat and Bioware's
award-winning storytelling are going to
come together into one unforgettable
experience for this section we brought
along a new party member someone
directly invested in our success Dorian
is a mage from the nation of two vinter
a place not well-loved in the south and
Dorian has joined the Inquisition with
the direct hopes of restoring the honor
of his homeland this defiance little
bird there's no one left for you to
protect you're wasting your breath
right I will die first oh you will feel
alive well that was impressive anger is
stronger than any pain do you have
weapons good the Magisters probably in
his chambers you aren't curious how we
got him no and majors always wonder why
people fear them no one should have this
power
what happened while we were away stop
talking I'm just asking for information
no you're talking to Phil silence
nothing happened that you want to hear
inquisitions focus on leadership means
that we needed to characters that were
sophisticated and believable once it
react not only to what you say but to
the actions that you take we're the ones
who sent Liliana in here she was
tortured and of course that will have a
damaging impact on a relationship every
major character that joins you in
Inquisition has their own story waiting
to be told explored and influenced by
your actions the breach it don't look
don't look [ __ ] I looked
what happened here somebody had very
questionable taste thus far we focused
mostly on the real time elements of
Dragon Age Inquisition combat but
another way to use your team effectively
is to use the tactical view to order
your followers into specific locations
assign them targets and exploit enemy
weaknesses with your abilities the
mandatory Spellbinder has a weakness too
cold make him a perfect target for one
of our ice spells and as we move our
camera we can sweep around the
battlefield identifying targets
opportunities and avenues of approach
seeing a natural choke point here we can
send iron bull to hold that position
with his life hopefully creating a
cluster of foes as we send our range
characters over to these positions in
order to hold them and rain death down
on our enemies at any point you can
choose to reengage time begin the
process of fighting and then alter your
orders adapting to this changing
tactical situation in front
what Anand Rastas name is that hold on
to it would looks it later whose present
in your party affects the story just as
much as it affects combat Dorian trained
under alexius the leader of the mages
were trying to stop and having Dorian in
our party and present for this encounter
gives us options that we otherwise
wouldn't have
in addition to team-based tactical
combat huge dragon encounters in the
massive open world to explore story
remains critical to the Dragon Age
series of games and here you'll get some
sense of the events that are driving
this story forward
Alexius it's time to answer for your
crimes and here you are finally I knew
you would appear again not that it would
be now but I knew I hadn't destroyed you
my final failure was it worth it
everything you did to the world to
yourself it doesn't matter now all we
can do is wait for the end
it does matter I will undo this how many
times have I tried the past cannot be
undone all that I fought for all that I
betrayed and what have I wrote ruin and
death that is nothing else the outer one
comes for me for you for us all Felix
its Felix makers breath alexius what
have you done he would have died Dorian
I saved him please don't hurt my son how
do anything you ask hand over the amulet
and we let him go home they can go and I
swear you get what you want I won the
world back
portable the elder one will destroy home
Espo's so much better by me Prairie your
assassin this time
the elder one who declares vote
already long
three elder one requires phone
yep that will be my apology
he wants it to die didn't he all those
lies he told himself the justifications
he lost Felix long ago didn't even
notice Oh Alexius I know you cared for
him once he was a man to whom I compared
to all others sad isn't it this is the
same immunity used before I think it's
the same one we made in min rathas
that's a relief give me an hour to work
out the spell he used I should be able
to reopen the rift an hour that's
impossible you must go now fake that's
how they won how it's one will head out
front keep them off your tail
cast your spell you have as much time as
I have errors
play and rafi guide me make take me
aside you move and we all die
Wow
this is the dragon age game we've always
wanted to make thank you so much for
checking it out